[Musica]
rosso bruciata dobbiamo completare le
tasche briosi giocatore nella storia di
maria ciao resto famiglie precisa ciao
ragazzi sbrighiamoci a fare le tasche
forse è meglio dire questo vetro così mi
vedete meglio molto meglio dobbiamo
iniziare subito con le nostre tasche e
sperare che l'impostore non si uccida
perché non sono io davvero ve lo giuro
non sono io ma sarete voi a doverlo
scoprire guardate il video fino alla
fine per scoprire chi è l'impostore non
spoiler a te niente nei commenti
lasciate un bel mi piace se questo video
raggiunge i 20 mila mi piace ci sarà la
seconda parte di among us nella vita
reale e ora sbrighiamoci iniziamo con la
nostra prima tas chissà cosa stanno
facendo rosso e nero
forse non mi sentite aspettate tolgo
questo vediamo molto che sia pronunciato
del tasc da completare qui sto vision al
tasto abbastanza facile però non farla
subito il codice qui troviamo 3 3 3 3 e
3 ok prima task fatta
andiamo a fare le altre tasca adesso
test taste treatment perché io non sono
un'impostora sono nate andiamo
[Musica]
ragazzi ho trovato una tasca qua sotto
guardate credo che devo unire i cavi
colorati il giallo con il giallo il
viola con il viola il rosso con il rosso
proviamo e vediamo cosa succede
fatto si sono collegati passiamo al
prossimo rosso col rosso anche il
secondo fatto ultimo cavo viola con
viola fatto ragazzi ho collegato tutti i
vili ho completato la task
ora cerchiamo altre tasche da completare
[Musica]
che cosa stava facendo rosa ancora
dentro
andiamo a controllare ha fatto qualcosa
di con cui i figli
devo andare a controllare meglio per
vedere se ha fatto bene usa ha sabotato
vediamo che cosa ha fatto qua sotto
secondo me rosa è sospetta questo sì al
giallo blu blu rosso giallo che stai
facendo lì che cosa vuoi perché stai
manomettendo i figli così de mauro bastò
manomettendo il feeling detto solo
controllando cai sta votando no non sto
sopportando ho voluto controllare perché
lo aspettavo che tu stessi sabotando
questi figli sono io sono io l'impostore
guarda che secondo me sei tu lippo
storia chi ha detto nipotino seduto
impostore ora la meeting di emergenza
nota major meetic.it emergenza è un
povero te come fa ma ciasca palla e nero
lato il patron rosanero
il rosso cosa aspettate viene qualcosa
meno voterà a mero cosa bomber 88
[Musica]
koussa il voto è finito in parità e
nessuno è stato espulso dalla navicella
spaziale nero chi avrà votato rosa o
rosso c'è qualcosa quando il computer
proviamo a fare questa task l'impostore
[Musica]
ok fatto ho completato anche questa task
ora cerchiamo oltre che cosa stavi
facendo stiamo completando la mia tyson
votando quella task non devi che ho
completato la task perché pensi che sono
io il bottone bene effettivamente sembra
proprio completata questa fase di mix
quindi sei tu no lo sono io l'impostore
[Musica]
guardate questa task che cosa vuol dire
cosa devo fare
se devo vedere i colori c'è qualcosa
quando un liquido blu
forse devo mettere il liquido blu nella
un po la brook vuota e questo liquido e
verde dovrà metterlo qua nell'ampolla
verde
proviamo speriamo che funzioni
non so perché sto bisbigliando non sto
facendo niente di sospetto sto facendo
le tasche da crew me it la palla gialla
con liquido verde
vediamo prima un po l'ha fatta seconda a
polla liquido blu
nell'ampolla blu
premiamo ora il pulsante tasto
completata cosa staranno facendo ora
rosso e nero troppo lento troppo veloce
troppo lento nuovamente troppo veloce
questa è la tasca più fastidiosa di
tutto e finora
[Musica]
questa task l'ho già fatta e mi fa paura
toccando il quadro elettrico qui fini
sembra che qualcuno mi abbia sabotato
qualcosa o no
la causa adesso bene ho finito quasi
tutte le il reattore
voglio vedere che cosa sta facendo
vedere dove rosso rosa rosa vista
manomettono reattori
no io non ho manomesso nessun reattore
sei qua è perché ho sentito l'allarme e
sono venuto qui per vedere che cosa stai
facendo sapevo che cosa fare devo
sbrigare
dove il rettore lo sapevo lo sapevo che
la rossa del motore spero solo che nero
server sicuro da rosso
ecco sono più volte abbiamo salvato il
rettore è riuscita a salvare il rettore
bene vero ma perché mi stai guardando
così ma tu non è nelle tasche da finire
da completare in effetti non ti ho visto
per tutto il giorno
che cosa stavi facendo ma non mi dire
che questo amore oro nero nero sarà in
pericolo perché hanno lasciato dopo il
rosso
abbiamo
[Musica]